hi
my name is craig and i'm the director of
product management for cloud ai platform
here at google cloud
platform today i'm going to be talking
to you about how to create value
with the breadth and depth of our ai
platform
creating value with the ai platform
simply comes down to
putting the best of google's ai
technologies to work for you
and for your company what does this mean
fundamentally this means how can we map
your business strategy to the right
ai absorption strategy we'll talk about
the different ways that google helps you
deploy ai without compromising on
flexibility
speed quality or scale
and finally we'll talk about some of the
customers that have transformed their
businesses
by tapping into the innovation from
google
as i think about ai fundamentally ai
only does
two things one it helps you grow your
market
increase subscribership increase users
increase their spend or increase their
conversion
or it helps you in the back end drive
efficiencies
reduce costs drive out waste from the
system
together these two capabilities allow
you
to achieve previously
unimaginable results for you and for
your company
using this critical technology
ai is not limited to this
business or that industry opportunities
to use ai can be found in every vertical
whether it's retail our capabilities in
health care
financial services things like lending
ai or anti-money laundering
media and entertainment or industrial
manufacturing with things like
visual inspection capabilities or public
sector
all of these are rich with opportunities
all of these are areas that we're
helping work on
with ai as you think about aia
investments and ai
absorption when you think about what
google offers you can really break it
down into three levels of investment
the first is ai out of the box this is
very low investment
very quick to market but doesn't come
with a lot of customization
the second is deploying custom ai this
on the other hand does allow for
customization takes a bit more effort
but is still very quick to market
and lastly is building end-to-end ai
this is when you and the data scientists
you work with
invest to build your own bespoke models
for areas where
this will be critical to your company's
strategic
innovation or your differentiation in
the market
we can think about these three levels
with this example
the first example of kind of the ai
right out of the box would be something
like optical character recognition
you could imagine simply calling our
vision api to quickly and easily
read the documents that you may have
second would be something like
potentially content classification
this is an area where the new york times
invested with us on
using automl to quickly and easily
classify their entire content library
and then finally
we come to actual pure insight
generation
deep investments that provide unique
benefit
this can be seen wonderfully with kaggle
an organization
that we run that has competitions for
data scientists and the work they've
been doing
seeking to extract critical findings
from the academic literature
around covalent sars viruses
these three levels of of understanding
can be
seen in our products as well at the
first layer
we see pre-trained apis these require no
real work from you to all you need to do
is integrate with the api
no data science is needed from you
instead
you can simply get your image labeled
get your document understood
uh you know do entity extraction or
sentiment analysis on your document
or in this case you can see using
pre-trained video apis to track movement
or track an object across
frames second would be custom ai with
automl
with this capability say our models
don't have
the objects you need labeled you want
specific fish
labeled not just that's a fish but you
want to know what species it is
you can take your own photos quickly and
easily label them with our data labeling
service
and then move them in and train your own
ai model
with no code having had been written and
finally for those more powerful models
or more interesting and bespoke use
cases
we offer the full end-to-end capability
with our core tools you can think of it
this way
across the top of the stack we have our
applications vision
and video conversation
language and structured data so whether
it's
labeling an image or working with video
whether it's speech to text text to
speech or setting up a conversational
bot
whether it's translation or entity
extraction
or sentiment analysis you have all of
your needs with our language
capabilities
and finally with structured data you can
build models on your structured data
without python or any sort of coding
required
then beneath those applications we have
the core
tools designed to help the data
scientists
build the powerful models they want to
both explore and build
whether it's notebooks as a service data
labeling
training as a service prediction as a
service all of the critical components
you'll need
to ensure that you're building the best
ai we're excited to announce some new
capabilities coming
for example later this year we'll have
new
improved workflows for automl within the
console
a fully integrated experience no longer
requiring
you to make specific decisions and
choices but instead making it all
easy right out of the box
you can see that with our stack you can
start by creating a data set
and then quickly and easily with no code
required move all the way through to a
model deployment
putting your model into production ready
to be called in a highly auto scaling
environment
now for those that wish to do something
more sophisticated or who wish to build
their own model
they'll have the full capability to do
so as well
as we move beyond automl one primary
area investment for us has been machine
learning ops or ml
ops in this area nothing has been as
exciting to us
as what we've seen customers do with our
managed pipelines
using those managed pipelines as well as
a feature store
continuous monitoring of models that are
in production
and metadata to help make decisions
customers will now be able to
support both a fully ci cd capability
as well as to start creating pipelines
that will support
much more sophisticated operations
such as quickly and easily retraining
your model once
skew or drift is detected these
pipelines what they do is they allow you
to take your monolith of
of code that you've used to build this
model and break it down into each of the
individual components
now it's much more easily debugged and
understood as well as these components
can be saved for future model usage
and in the future when you are building
a model instead of starting with a
blinking cursor
you can simply go in pipelines and start
pulling the most commonly used pipelines
down into your model
to use for things like extracting data
validating data or evaluating the model
these capabilities significantly reduce
the time of experimentation
we had one customer telling us that they
have increased their rate of
experimentation
by 7x using this technology
we couldn't be more excited to see how
your company will use this
finally as is critical to any service of
this type
metadata management is is a key piece of
what we
we believe is needed to effectively run
a mlaps environment
whether that's automatic metadata
logging from our
hosted services or custom metrics that
you may want to devise
both are quickly and easily captured and
then can be used for things like
compliance ml ops continuous training
and continuous delivery
or experimentation development model and
artifact comparisons
as well as improved ml reproducibility
and explainability
the compliance story here is an
interesting one it allows you to do
previously very difficult tasks things
like imagine that if a customer said hey
please remove me from your records all
you would have to do is remove the
customer from
the data set in question or from all of
the data sets that they're in
and then with pipelines and ml metadata
you could very quickly and easily auto
retrain just
just by determining the fact that the
data set hadn't changed automatically
retrained the model and redeployed the
model
or without a human ever having to write
code to do so
we're proud of our ai platform because
our ai platform does three things really
well
one it meets our users where they are
two it quickly deploys the highest
quality ai
and three it allows you to scale and
streamline that ai
in unbelievable ways
meeting customers where they are what
does that mean well as you can see here
i think we all fall somewhere on the
spectrum of skills and capabilities
within machine learning
and whether you're someone who's just
starting out or whether you're someone
who's already comfortable with the most
sophisticated tooling
we have solutions for you when we talk
about meeting customers where they are
there's two companies that are
interesting to call out the first is
cruz
cruz is an autonomous vehicle company
making tremendous strides in moving to a
world where my son will never have to
get his driver's license
with this cruise builds models and we
have worked closely with them on
optimizing their environments and
optimizing their tensorflow capabilities
to decrease their training times so that
they can more quickly and more easily
cycle through experiments and move
towards a world in which
cars are fully autonomous now on the
other side
is the city of memphis the city of
memphis not traditionally known as a
tremendous machine learning powerhouse
but in this case they were actually
building a model very similar to ones
that cruz has no doubt had to build
the city of memphis wanted to understand
where they had
the most problematic potholes so they
used automl
to build a pothole detector and sure
enough we're able to save twenty
thousand dollars a year
in the reduction in claims costs due to
these unaddressed potholes
as you can imagine these two customers
come with very different skills and
expertise
and both were able to find tremendous
value with google and its platform
we do seek as i said to meet customers
where they are
so for example our ai notebooks not only
do they come pre-prepared for
the use of classic or traditional ml
frameworks such as tensorflow or pi
torch
but they also have data analytics
capabilities so that you can get a
big data image with things like apache
beam pre-installed so that you can
quickly and easily manage your own data
proc
cluster explainability is at the heart
of understanding our machine learning
we believe heavily and have invested
heavily in this space
as you can see at the top of the slide
are images
of explainability showing what
pixels in particular the model may have
used to render its judgment
down below on the slide are is a picture
of feature importance
from a tabular use case both of these
provide tremendous value to
data scientists and both understanding
them why the model is doing what it's
doing
as well as ensuring that the model is
doing what it's supposed to be doing
we don't think of explainability and
explainable ai as some separate field
that
you know can only be used by the experts
we believe it's central and as such
we include it with every prediction in
our prediction service
we simply publish all of the
explainability results
in the same blogs we publish your
inferences so that you can go back and
look to see if you're experiencing
unexpected
drift or skew so that you'll know when
it's time to retrain the model
not only do we like to meet customers
where they are but we ensure that we can
quickly deploy the highest quality ai
for easy business outcomes this might be
in the area of site
language conversation or with structured
data
in the area of site we're excited to
work with box
box is using our vision api to help
their customers
manage and gain insights from their
image files
and speed up image centric processes and
workflows
whether it's the work that box is doing
or whether it's
image and video search or industrial
inspection
our vision capabilities are unparalleled
in the market
next would be translation natural
language capabilities whether it's
entity extraction document
classification
sentiment analysis or in this case
translation
bloomberg is a company that sells
information and for bloomberg to be able
to quickly and easily
sell that information in whatever
language their customer speaks
is a critical capability you can imagine
how breaking down the divide of
languages
might be beneficial to your business
next with speech voice and
conversational bots whether it's speech
to text
text-to-speech video transcription voice
commands
all of this is made possible with these
capabilities
and we're excited about the work we've
done with domino's using dialog flow
so that they could meet all of their
goals and milestones
as they quickly and easily deployed a
model
to allow customers to quickly and easily
order
through the use of a conversational bot
finally it comes down to structured data
structured data is what many of our
businesses run on whether it's in our
data warehouse
in the business systems we may have
running
now usually when we talk about machine
learning we talk about
very complex and kind of
in very important use cases sometimes
though it's okay for ai to be fun
and this is one of those models we
partnered with fox sports and they used
our automl
tables capability our structured data
capability to build a model
that would predict when the next wicket
would fall in cricket
now for those who aren't cricket fans or
for those who are
this you know may not seem all that
exciting but i will say that they
increased their app usage
they also increased viewership as well
as reduced a number of critical cost
metrics
and customer attainment because
customers were so interested and curious
now all of a sudden when i'm watching
i can simply pay attention to the part
of the
match that i know is going to be
relevant or i may simply want to tune in
to see how well the ai actually predicts
the outcomes
finally the ability to scale and
streamline
with ease this fundamentally comes down
to
google passing over many of its
well-built systems so that you can use
them in your
environment so that you have the same
power of
scale that google brings to the table
nothing shows this better probably than
etsy
who when joining gcp realized that they
wanted to sort through and index
over 40 billion images
working with us we were able to help
them increase efficiency by 15
in doing this as i mentioned before
ai notebooks are a critical way that
many of our users interact with our
services
i can think back to the days when
managing a machine learning team
and how many of our data scientists at
the end of the day would pack their
laptops into their backpack and head
home for the evening
with their notebooks saved locally and
probably a significant amount of data
saved locally
with our cloud notebooks available to
you
that's never again a concern our cloud
notebooks come with tremendous levels of
security
including data exfiltration capabilities
so that you know that both your code
and your data is safe when your
employees are using
cloud ai and our ai platform notebooks
finally uh our ai platform prediction
service
our ai platform prediction service
allows you access to some of the most
cutting edge hardware
things like nvidia's t4 gpus it
automatically logs
all of your inferences the incoming
payload of information
as well as those explanatory variables
and we log all of that in bigquery so
that you have quick and easy access
to doing some of the analysis on it
finally it scales automatically with
traffic
all you have to do is tell us what kind
of processor you want running it
and how high up you would want us to
scale if
the traffic comes and as the traffic
comes we will automatically add those
resources so that you're only paying
when you actually
are seeing that traffic
as i mentioned before ai platform
pipelines is a transformational
technology for many teams
seeing a 7x increase in the rate of
experimentation
all of a sudden makes problems that were
previously unsolvable solvable
now all of a sudden work that would have
taken me a week may take me a day or
work that may have taken me
months may take me only a week with the
power of that kind of velocity increase
you can only imagine the capabilities
that your machine learning or data
science team may be able to affect
tensorflow enterprise tensorflow
enterprise
is uniquely available on google cloud
tensorflow enterprise does three things
first of all it gives you cloud scale
performance with highly optimized
binaries to allow
things like increased i o speeds so that
you can see
improved training or prediction also
it's used in all of our managed services
so you know that if you're using
training as a service
or inference as a service you're
protected by tensorflow enterprise
i'd say protected because the third
aspect is support
many of us have many have concerns
about using open source in production
can you trust that it will be well
supported with security patches and bug
fixes
we're excited to say that with
tensorflow enterprise
we extend the one year of support that
tensorflow gives
to three full years of support so that
you
your i.t department and your business
can be comfortable
ensuring that the that this software
is fully protected from security and bug
fixes
for the full duration of the life of
your model
all of this comes back into the ai
platform whether it's the applications
for vision
conversation language and structured
data
or whether it's the core services of
notebook as a service or training as a
service or pipelines
that you may want to use all of it we
are excited
to partner with you to build models that
go beyond your
expectations finally to wrap it all up
first map your business objectives
to a relevant ai strategy don't
ask how this technology can help you
figure out what you need help with and
then let's figure out the right
technology to use
second partner with a company that has
tremendous experience
deploying ai at scale we have learned
from our mistakes we have learned them
already
you don't need to relearn them finally
plan for the end-to-end ai life cycle
beyond just the model training by using
pipelines
you have the capability to create a full
ci cd system
a system that will relearn as soon as
the model starts to become stale or
starts to give
irrelevant results
google has been called out by a number
of organizations for our leadership and
machine learning
you can see here in forrester's wave
they're
for their computer vision platforms that
they've named google as a leader
similarly in gartner's magic quadrant
cloud ai's developer services
magic quadrant google was named a leader
in 2020.
with awards across the industry we are
very proud
of what we have built and very excited
to work with customers like you
on building and deploying new and
exciting models
with that i would like to allow one of
our customers to speak for a moment on
how they've unlocked the value of ai
with google cloud
cardinal health has about 50 000
employees across 46 countries
our mission is to be essential to health
care we provide products and services so
that the healthcare providers can focus
on their patients
the industry has evolved over the last
five to ten years the world is basically
moving to personalization machine
learning and artificial intelligence
and we really just had a great
connection culturally
work ethic and also some co-innovation
with google cloud
cardinal health's first machine learning
project
went live in google cloud every day we
have 2500
emails coming in from the customer
through our sap
crm system with different messages
different
intentions so we have to send it to the
human routers
a group of 40 people who are sorting and
categorize the email
before we send it to the agents to
perform the tasks
that is a very labor-intensive process
we leveraged google cloud native
services
and created ml model that automatically
sorted our emails
we used the human categorized emails
so we learned how the categorization can
be done
in machine learning and then we deployed
our model
into google cloud the people that we
freed up
through the machine learning they move
on to do the actual work
rather than sorting the emails we are
very happy about this
project because it's a milestone for us
we proved that it's achievable and it's
really improved customer service our ai
platform of choice
is google cloud
we're very lucky to get to work with
cardinal health and
we're very lucky to see some of the
solutions that they have been able to
deploy
with that here are some resources if
you're interested and would like to
learn more about our ai products or
about our build and use ai capabilities
thank you for your time today and i look
forward to meeting you and hopefully
working with you
on deploying exciting ai for your
business